Welcome back.
I think I was rushing
that problem.
So let me just make it clear
again, just so you don't get
confused, because I was
trying to get under
that 10-minute limit.
But they want to know what
the perimeter of
this red is, right?
That's kind of the outside of
this thing that looks like a
flower or something.
And what I'm saying is that the
perimeter of the red part
is equivalent to the sum of
the perimeters of the
rectangle-- of the triangle,
sorry-- the sum of the
perimeters of the triangles.
But if I were just to take the
sum of the perimeters of the
triangle, I wouldn't just
be getting the red part.
I'd also be getting in
these parts, right?
Because those are parts of the
perimeters of the triangles.
So if I want just the red part,
I subtract out this,
what I just drew in blue, and
the blue is the perimeter of
that inside square.
And the perimeter of that inside
square is 9 plus 9 plus
9 plus 9, or 36.
So I just take the perimeter
of all four triangles.
Each of them has a perimeter of
30, so together they have a
perimeter of 120, and then
subtract out the perimeter of
the square inside, which
has a perimeter of 36.
So 120 minus 36 is what?
84.
Right, 84.
That's choice D.
Next problem.
Let me remember that this is
where I ended the last one.
OK, next problem.
Problem number 13.
The graph of g of x
is shown above.
OK, I'd better draw it because
they want us to essentially
look at the graph and
figure out a value.
Well, let's see, it starts at
roughly-- so if I were to--
let's see, 2, 4, 6, 8.
And we have 2, 4, 6, 8, 10.
I'll try my best to draw it like
they have. So the line
starts roughly a little bit
above 6, not even up to 7.
And then, where does it go?
It goes to like 4.
Oh my God, I thought I was
using the line tool.
It starts a little bit above
6, not even up to 7.
It looks like about at 1.
It starts here, then it goes
to the point 4 comma 2, it
looks like.
And then it goes from 4 comma
2 to 6 comma 3, roughly.
Or maybe even exactly.
6 comma 3.
And then it looks like
it goes to 8 comma 8.
8 comma 8 is like
there, roughly.
That's about right.
And then it goes down to like--
I don't know-- almost
11 comma 2.
It goes to someplace like that,
and they're saying this
is the graph of g of x.
And they're saying, if g of 2
is equal to k, which of the
following could be the
value of g of k?
g of k is what?
So what could k equal?
Let's figure out g of 2.
So when x is 2, bum, bum, bum,
bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
what is y equal to?
Well, it looks pretty darn close
to 5, if not exactly 5.
So k is equal to 5, right?
g of 2 is equal to 5, right?
And they want to know
what g of k is.
Well, we figured out that k is
equal 5, so now we want to
know what g of 5 is.
So we go to 5.
We go, bup, bup,
bup, bup, bup.
This is 5.
And then we go bup, bup, bup,
bup, bup, bup, bup, bup, bup.
Looks pretty close to 3.
g of 5-- and actually the way
they drew it, it doesn't look
close to 3.
The way they drew it, if you
look at where 5 is, it looks
actually less than 3.
It looks like 2 and
1/2, actually, the
way they drew it.
My drawing is a little off.
So if you look down, look
at the x value.
When x is equal to 5, you go up
to the graph, it looks like
the graph value there is
right around 2 and 1/2.
So I should say this
is 2 and 1/2.
And that is one of
the choices, B.
Next problem.
Problem 14.
If 0 is less than or equal to x,
which is less than or equal
to 8, and negative 1 is less
than equal to y, which is less
than or equal to 3, which of the
following gives the set of
all possible values
of x times y?
OK, so we really just want to
figure out how low can x times
y be and how high can
x times y be?
Well, what's the lowest possible
value for x times y?
Well, if we make y negative, and
we make x really big, or
as big as it can be, if x is 8
and y is negative 1, then that
is the lowest value for x
times y I can think of.
So xy is going to be greater
than or equal to negative 8
because when you take a negative
number, you want the
other number to be as big as
possible so you get a large
negative number.
And it's going to be less than
or equal to-- well, what's the
largest number that
I can think of?
Well, if I take 8 and I multiply
it times the large
value of y and this is a
positive value, then I get 24.
So xy is going to be greater
than or equal to negative 8
and less than or equal to 24.
And that is choice E.
And once again, how did
I get negative 8?
This is probably the part that's
not intuitive for you.
It's because-- I mean, your
instinct might have said the
minimum x is 0, right?
So I'll take 0 times any
of these, so this
is going to be 0.
But, you can actually get a
smaller value for xy by using
negative 1 and 8, so
that's where we got
the negative 8 from.
Next question.
15.
Switch colors.
Let me draw that.
It looks like a line there, line
there, line there, then
there's another line that
goes like that.
And they write that this is
n degrees right there.
In the figure above, what is
this sum in terms of n of the
degree measures of the four
angles marked with arrows?
Fascinating.
So they want to know that plus
that plus that plus that.
Well, let's just do
the angle game.
If this angle as n, well, then
this angle is n, right?
Let me switch colors.
What is this angle here?
Well, it's supplementary to
n, so this is 180 minus n.
And so is this.
This is also 180 minus n.
And so what are these?
What's the sum of these
two angles?
Let me call this a, b.
What's the sum of a plus b?
Well, we know that a plus b
plus this angle, plus 180
minus n is equal
to 180, right?
Because they're all in
the same triangle.
So a plus b is equal to
180 minus 180 plus n.
I just took this and subtracted
180 and added n to
both sides.
This cancels out so you get
a plus b is equal to n.
And similarly, if you had c,
if this were c and d, you
could do the same thing.
c plus d plus this angle, 180
minus n is equal to 180
because they're all in
the same triangle.
Subtract 180 from both sides and
then add n to both sides.
You get c plus d
is equal to n.
So if you want to know what a
plus b plus c plus d is, a
plus b is n, c plus d is n, so
the whole thing is going to be
n plus n or 2n.
And that is choice B.
Let's see if I have time to do
problem 16, considering I have
a little under a minute left.
Problem 16.
After the first term, each term
in a sequence-- actually,
this is going to be-- I think
this will take some
explanation, so I'll do 16
in a video by itself.
I'll see you in the
next video.